need a ride girl it's bigger on the  inside  do you play Quidditch cuz you look like  a keeper were you forged by Sauron cuz  baby you are precious  are you a carbon sample cuz I want to  date you part in my tangent but what's  your sign let's go to the bedroom I'll  show you why they call me the dungeon  master girl you must be the Human Torch  because you are on fire are you why fire  cuz I feel a connection do you want to  know what I keep in my utility belt  my name is Windows can I crash at your  place do you have 11 protons because you  are sodium 5 that's no moon mind if I  slid there into your chamber of secrets  girl like it's been a millennium in your  Falcon if I were an enzyme I'd be DNA  helicase so I could unzip your jeans you  know what a Velociraptor sounds like  when it's in heat do you have a  girlfriend I volunteer as tribute five  eight zero zero eight upside down let's  get it on like Donkey Kong set phasers  just stunning  girl yeah okay although